- [Interviewer] All
right. All right, Loddy.
Loddy, where'd you grow up,
where you from originally?
- [Loddy] From Los Angeles, California.
South Central.
- [Interviewer] South Central?
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- [Loddy] Got mama and dad.
- [Interviewer] Good childhood?
- Excellent, perfect.
- [Interviewer] Really?
That's nice to hear.
And what kind of kid
were you in high school?
- A sneaky kid.
(interviewer laughs)
I always wanted to get into everything.
Wanted to get by past everything
without nobody knowing.
Never liked the homework,
never liked the teachers.
I didn't like them telling
me nothing most of the time.
I really didn't like
waking up in the morning
even going to school.
I liked to go to school in the daytime.
Like, I didn't really too
much even like school.
- [Interviewer] Did
you finish high school?
- Maybe, halfway.
- [Interviewer] So, today you're working
as a prostitute?
- Yeah, you could say that.
- [Interviewer] And at what age
did you start doing that?
- Um...
I say about like 15.
- 15?
- I was maybe 15.
15, 14, somewhere in there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
that's a common story.
And how'd you get started?
Did you know somebody that was doing it?
Did you have friends?
Did you...
- No, I would always see people around
the neighborhood or my friends
or my friends' friends
or my sister friends maybe,
people I seen at school or I always
seen the videos or I seen the fly girls
with the jewelry, the
money, the car, you know,
like I always wanted
things like that of my own,
like without asking Mom and Dad.
So I knew it was only
one way to get it though
was to have a job, but
them I'm like fuck a job,
like, it's, what's in the streets?
I wanna know what the ghetto girls doing
in the streets.
And I stepped off the porch
and starting hanging outside
and meeting friends that knew friends
that had friends and,
you know, I got around.
- [Interviewer] Do you
recall your first time?
The first guy that picked you up?
- Um, no, I was at a
club and I met somebody.
And I was getting into
it with one of my friends
to be exact and I wanted
to leave the club early
and they didn't wanna take me,
so a guy was like, "I'll
give you a ride home.
Like, "Yeah?"
And I was so mad, so I was like,
"Fuck it, let's go."
And he gave me a ride home
and on the way home he
was all talking to me,
whatever, telling me I was cute
and et cetera and et cetera
and I was, I wasn't really like buying it,
like I wasn't paying him no attention,
like I wasn't really like acknowledging
what he was saying.
I was just, I was fading
and I was mad at the fact of all,
everything with involved, like,
and he was all like, um,
"You don't wanna go home yet,
you wanna go chill?"
And I'm like, like, "My time is money,"
and like, you know, I was young,
I was hot, like, you know,
I was a hot girl back then.
Well, then and still probably
now, you know, 'cause...
- [Interviewer] You still are.
- Right, you know.
- You still are.
- But, um...
I say in my younger days, like I was,
I was the shit, so I was always like
"My time is money and if I gotta sit here
and talk to you, you gotta
pay me for everything,
like you know the time's
ticking like, you know."
And he was like, "What you mean by that?"
I'm like, "Well, the longer I sit
in the car with you, the more
money you have to pay me."
He was like, "Oh, I gotta give you money?"
I'm like, "Yeah, you
wanna spend time with me,
want to chill."
He was like, "All right,
let's go to the room."
And he was like, um,
"I'll give you 200 bucks,"
he's like, "to go chill
in the other room."
I was like, "Go chill with you at the room
for just 200 bucks."
I'm like, "How long we gonna be there?"
He was like, um, "We can
chill for a few hours,"
but he's like, "I'll get
the room for the rest
of the night until the morning."
I was thinking to myself like,
fuck him, a woman not gonna be trippin'.
She know after the club, I normally go
to my homegirl's house
or I come in, I go home.
It's like, fuck that, I'm a chill out
till the morning, fuck it.
Everybody gonna be lookin' for me.
I'm gonna come back with money.
That's all I was thinking about,
just the money.
So, I went to the room with the nigga.
We actually chilled,
like, you know, got high.
I was being sneaky, see,
then I was sniffin' coke,
you know, I was doin' drugs, oh my God,
I was terrible.
- [Interviewer] At 15?
- At 15, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I was livin' on 11th and Broadway.
You know, I was gettin' high,
we got faded and whatever or what not.
The morning came, he
broke me off, you know,
and, you know, that was
pretty much after that.
But now I done, you know, experience more,
seen more, know more, so, you know,
every dollar counts.
- [Interviewer] What have you learned
in your years of doing this?
How dangerous it is?
- I mean, yeah, it could be dangerous,
'cause I done been through some shit.
Like I done been, I done got in cars
with certain people and they either try
to fight me, stab me, all type of shit
because somethin' ain't going they way
and just stuff got out of hand, yeah.
You can, you can die out there actually.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. You been arrested?
- Oh, yeah.
I got arrested.
My friend, she wanted, well, I was walking
down the street one day from my house,
which is on 11th and Broadway,
I was walkin' down the street
to my homie T-Way house and
it was this little bitch
that he had and she wanted to,
she wanted to learn how
to date tricks and shit,
but he wanted to put the bitch down on Fig
and on the Third.
So I'm like, "I'll take
her, like I'll show
her what's up."
He was like, "Show that bitch, Loddy."
I'm like, "Fo sho."
So, me and the bitch, we go on Fig.
We out there.
I'm telling her like pay attention
to certain cars, like, you know,
you get in a car with some person
or he won't touch you or he's like
too shaved off or too bald or, you know,
in the face or something like,
don't talk to him.
Like, if they don't touch you first,
But this time I got in a car with her.
They guy wanted to date her in the car.
I'm like, "Well, while you guys date
in the back, I'll drive."
Mind you, I'm only 15.
The man gave me the keys to his car.
I'm driving down the one-way.
Doo, doo, doo, doo.
The police pull us over.
I'm thinking the guy was vice.
He wasn't even vice, it was,
it was really a, you know, a customer
and they stopped us
and when they put us out the car,
she was naked, he was naked.
They had the helicopters on us.
Oh, my God, it was like
the most embarrassing date ever
because when they stopped us,
they stopped us in front
of some black people house,
the niggas came outside.
And it was all lookin' like y'all got this
little young girl with y'all.
'Cause I was a young cat, you know.
They was looking on me like
what you doing drivin' a car
with a girl and a nigga?
You know?
So, they took me to jail, you know.
My brother, he came down and talked to me,
'cause you know my brother, he's LAPD,
he's a sheriff, as well.
So, I went to the 8th police station.
I was so embarrassed because
they was telling me like,
"Who are your family, and
how can we contact them,
'cause it's like we can't take you to jail
because you're underage" and
da da this and da da that
and I was all being big mouthed
and like, "I ain't not
family," and what the woo,
so they finally got me
to tell them my name.
When I tell them my name, they was like,
"We got somebody that wanna talk to you."
Like, I was thinking about it at the time,
but I wasn't really thinking.
They go put me in this little office,
sit me in this chair,
they take the cuffs off me,
they only handcuffed me once
to the chair or whatever.
It was like, "Sit right here,
somebody gonna come talk to you."
So, I'm sitting there, sitting there,
time go by.
My brother walk in there
and he was like, "Lucas."
I couldn't even look at him.
The whole time I was there
I never gave him eye contact.
We never contacted eyes the whole time.
Like once I seen him walk in
and I knew it was him,
like my brother, Anthony,
like literally my brother,
like I grew up from like, you know?
Oh, my God, I was like,
I swear to God it was like shocking.
It was something like a person
can never just like experience
or see like, you know.
Not a shocking or a surprising,
it was like, like
irrational like, you know.
- [Interviewer] You're ashamed
of it? Of your situation?
- I was. I was embarrassed.
I felt humiliated. I felt
like, like, you know?
Like, oh, my gosh.
And then I felt as bad on his behalf, too,
because, you know he works there.
And he was just, he was talking to me-
- [Interviewer] It's
embarrassing for him and for you.
- Yeah, it is. His little sister at that.
His baby sister out there, you know,
running it up, just, you know?
He was talking to me like,
I can't even tell you right now
what he was saying to me
because he was saying stuff to me
and I was just, everything
just is beaming in my head.
I'm just thinking like oh, I
done fucked up now for real.
- [Interviewer] So, you've
worked with pimps before?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And are you
currently working with a pimp?
- I mean...
I mean, you could say no, yeah, no, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Okay, we don't need to,
you don't need to answer.
In the past when you've worked with pimps,
let's word it that way,
how were those, how were
those relationships?
- Oh, see, I was always the, you know,
I was young then so I was always
the first one, you know, like,
all the bitches used to get mad
because he would treat me
some type of different way,
like I didn't have to be that bitch
that have to get put down every day
or nothing like, you know, I got the,
you know, get my way, you
know, I was like a madam,
young, though, you know.
- [Interviewer] You got special treatment?
- Oh, my God. It was lovely.
Like, I don't know.
I got the book smartness
to the street smartness.
I put it together.
Like, you know, like so, my gang was kind
of too tight for it, like, I started off
really kind of young at that shit,
so, as time grew and I
grew, it like, you know,
I got too book smart for that shit.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about the,
the relationship with the pimp.
I mean so many of my viewers
are just mystified as
to why a female would...
- I mean, because it's protection.
- [Interviewer] It's protection, right?
- I mean, he's gonna come,
he's gonna do whatever he needs to do to,
at the end of the day
satisfy the bitch, as well,
and make sure that she's
safe, she got that comfort,
like, you know, he's there,
he's like he's saving her,
like, you know what I'm saying?
And she get what she want
from her time, like...
- [Interviewer] So, you're
giving him all your money?
- Yeah, every, every, yeah.
- [Interviewer] But-
- It's, I mean, that's the beauty of it.
That's the whole concept of
being a prostitute, you know?
You're like, you're
like a, um, an ongoing,
you're an ongoing bitch that
just can't help herself,
but the, to fuckin' get money.
It's no other way you could put it.
That's just straight
blank, like pure point,
just, you know, you get out there
and get the money and pay him.
- [Interviewer] But it's
not a situation that you
are opposed to?
It's something that kind
of works for a girl, right?
- [Interviewer] I mean, yeah, sometimes
you got to use what you
got to get what you want.
Why not?
You don't have to necessarily always fuck
a motherfucker, neither
to get what you want.
You know? Like, I got a mouthpiece.
Like, you know.
I'm not saying like suckin'
dick wise, like, but-
- [Interviewer] I know.
- You know, like, you know?
- Oh, I know.
- You have to have some
type of ism as well,
not just only his ism, you know,
but you gotta have, you know.
You got, that's something,
being a prostitute, you have to really
be dedicated to it, you know.
That's something you have to really want.
Like you can't just be a
loose bitch out there running
just like, oh, I gotta
a pimp, hootie whoo,
'cause he's down to beat your ass.
Like you don't pay him his money,
you don't come in right,
you don't go by his rules,
you gonna be beat the fuck up.
He gonna, you know.
He can does that, 'cause he's your daddy,
you know what I'm sayin'?
Like it's something you sign up for.
It's like sometimes it's,
it's no way outta that shit,
'cause he, that's all he knows,
that's all he, that's how he survives,
that's how he eat, you know?
- [Interviewer] Mm-hmm. Is it-
- It's a lot to it, though.
- [Interviewer] Is it
easy for a girl to get out
if she wants to get out
of that relationship?
- Oh, yeah, she gonna pay
him whatever he wants.
- [Interviewer] So you
have to pay to get out?
- Hell, yeah.
Hell, yeah.
Or you wouldn't be able to sell,
not lick a coochie nowhere.
- [Interviewer] So how
much do you make in a night
of doing this?
Or how much do you bring
in and give to your pimp?
- See, I mean,
I'm, I don't know.
I'm different from a lot of girls, like,
guys when they say me,
they always be like,
"You're cute, you got
titties," and da, da, da.
"I like your smile and you
got white pretty teeth,
and you don't look like
that type of girl,"
so, you know, I get paid,
I get tipped, I get
extra, over pay, you know?
I ain't no joke. I don't play.
Once time tick, like once
I'm on the, on the clock
until time stop, oh, yeah, it's no games.
Every, I mean every second, every minute,
I don't play no fuckin' games.
- [Interviewer] And are some-
- Even for interviews,
like when a guy pull up
and I probably not really
want to or whatever, you know,
like for my time, like, what's up?
(speaking foreign language)
- [Interviewer] You want money
just to talk to him in the car?
- (speaking foreign language)
I know Spanish, as well, too,
so it goes both way for me.
- [Interviewer] And are
some interactions more,
not so much sex for money,
but sometimes you're figuring out how to
get the guy's watch or
jewelry or wallet or
stuff like that?
- Oh, you, oh, yeah, 'cause he, look it,
some guy's they'll pull up,
they wanna date you,
you'll get there, date them
and they'll be like, "Oh, I have to go
to the bank for my money,"
and then they try to pull a fast one.
Your first instincts is gonna be
take everything in his pockets.
Take his wallet, his keys, everything.
Strip him asshole naked.
See now, now it's a ballgame,
'cause now it's like my way or no way
or the highway.
And at the end of the day
it's gonna be highway for me
to get the fuck up outta there
and he's gonna be asshole naked
without nothing until my daddy gets there
or whatever, whatever.
Nine times outta 10,
I'm gonna try to solve
the issue before he get here,
'cause I know know how
ugly they get, you know?
So I'm a do what I have to do,
leave him stranded and
take off with everything.
- [Interviewer] That's just
the way the game works.
- Yeah.
But in the process of all that,
it gets kinda dirty.
A lot of things can happen.
Something will happen. It's
a situation. It's a problem.
That's where that part come in
where you can get yourself killed and hurt
'cause some of them
motherfuckers, they fight back.
They fight back and then, you know,
they put up for it, you know,
they put a little fight up for they shit.
But it be like, you know,
you in the wrong, so,
it is what it is.
That's why certain girls get raped now
'cause some guys, they'll pay
before they get their job done
or they blow jobs or they sex
or whatever and what not,
like they'll just break off the bitch
and the bitch'll run off, you know?
So I don't blame certain, certain tricks
that do date bitches and it happen,
like I don't blame them for that,
like, you know, it makes it hard
for a person like me, like, you know,
pay up and get what you want, you know.
Some niggas, they don't do that now.
They be like, "Fuck that bitch,
I want you to do me first, bitch,
and them I'm a pay you."
You know, so it be iffy like ah.
Those ones like that,
I be like, pshh (imitating
tires squealing).
[Interviewer] What kind
of guys do you pick up?
Or what kind of guys pick you up?
- I don't how I attract all the ballers
for some odd reason.
I'm not bushin' you, I ain't tryna say
I'm all that, but I attract all the,
the right ones and it be like, ah.
Like, you know.
- [Interviewer] I could see that.
- They be like, they be
tryna be so petty with me
when I be saying a whole like, ooh, ooh.
But, I be, you know.
I get my share.
I make sure I get my portion.
Believe that.
But, you know, the good is for the good
and the bad is for the bad.
- [Interviewer] And are drugs part
of the picture for you?
- The drugs? Oh, yeah, I
was a coke head, terribly.
I swear I, I used to
have so many coke nights
and days like, I can
never not remember like,
a drug is a motherfucker,
it's a hellified thing to do.
Once you start doing a drug
and you already in the
streets (whistling),
it's all, it's a hard pillow to swallow.
I'm telling you, it's like, it's hard,
it's hard to grab back
because it's be like
you get so deep into it
and you been to the streets
and to the gang life, the money just,
just the whole, the
emperor, just everything,
like, you know, it be...
And don't be livin' at a
good wealth home, you know,
like with a roof over your head,
like where you could sleep every night,
you got hot water, you got, you know,
you got gas, electricity,
you know what I'm saying?
You got clothes.
You don't have worry about for the bitches
get tampons every month and all that,
don't fuck that over.
I'm tellin' you, 'cause it's hard
to get that shit back,
it's hard, very hard.
And it's not easy to get out of it, like,
it's easy to jump in,
but to get that right back tight,
it'll never be the same.
- [Interviewer] That's why a lot
of the girls don't save money, right?
The drug habit gets outta control.
- Oh, yeah.
See, then, that's where the pimp 'posed
to step in.
Some of 'em don't give a fuck.
Some of 'em let the
bitches burn themself out
and go to the next bitch.
That's why pimps got one,
two, three four, five,
they got plenty.
What one won't do, the next
one will, believe that.
- [Interviewer] Does this lifestyle get
you down sometimes?
- You say what?
- [Interviewer] Do you
get depressed sometimes
just from doing this?
- Hell, yeah.
'Cause it's like,
I miss, I miss me goin' and
comin' and seein', like,
I done been I don't know how many places
without my parents by me being underage
and everything, like I done seen a lot.
I done been from here and there,
like I done been to Talexico,
I don't been to Mexico,
I done been to Tijuana (exhaling).
I done been to New Orleans
and it's hard to believe.
I done been to Vegas,
I done been to Texas,
I done been...
Where was that we went to?
- [Interviewer] Florida?
- No, I didn't go to Florida.
Where did we go?
Oh, we went to Miami.
- [Interviewer] That's Florida.
- Oh, it's Florida? Okay,
there you go, my bad, okay.
- [Interviewer] You told me that earlier.
- Yeah.
Um, where else did we go?
On, we went on a trip to the Bahamas
with my friend, Mal
one time, two, as well,
I was young, nigga, oh, my God.
It was one summer vacation.
Ooh, we had fun.
- [Interviewer] But this is a pimp
who organizes these trips?
- Oh, yeah, 'cause, look
it, believe it or not,
I had this, I had this friend named Todd,
and he would come visit me.
I was like 17, 16
and my mama found out,
so I stopped fuckin'
with the nigga, but he was on me so hard,
like to where he would just come and just
drop me off bills just because, like,
just ah, ah, ah.
I'm like, "I can't talk to you,
like, my mom know and, like, you know,
it's gonna get ugly for you."
He start payin' me to talk to my friends,
like my friends' moms and all that.
Oh, my, like every other week the nigga
come drop me off two,
three, five hundred bills,
just go get him a girl,
make sure she right.
He gonna break me off before anything
and when I come back break me off.
Oh, my, it used to be crazy.
He'd come find me wherever I'm at,
come and find me, far,
wherever, it doesn't matter.
Like, the game gets deep.
- [Interviewer] Does your
family know you do this?
- I mean, for the ones
that really know me.
- [Interviewer] What are
the personality traits
that you have that help you do this?
You're very confident.
- Yeah.
I'm good at anything.
I try, I try not to be perfect sometimes,
but my intentions is
on just slammin' on it,
just, you know.
- [Interviewer] I got a feeling
that you'd be good at
whatever you put your mind to.
- [Loddy] Yeah, I am.
- [Interviewer] It's just interesting
that you put your mind to this.
- [Loddy] Right.
- [Interviewer] What do you think led you
down this path?
- [Loddy] Lack of stress, just,
I'm comin' to that point like,
where I feel like I'm going down
this little brick road, like, you know,
and it's like once you
get to that brick road,
there's nowhere to turn to,
nowhere to go, nowhere to, for nothing,
so it's like before you get that far,
it's like stop.
Think about it.
Like do I wanna continue
on living like this,
like when I don't have to at that.
Pssh.
I can have it all made out,
but I choose to go my route.
I choose to go my way,
I choose to get money how I
get money, like, you know.
I survive on my own.
I don't even have a job, anything.
I don't even get GR.
Nothing, nothing.
I don't gets no type of income at all.
Period point blank.
[Interviewer] And you don't pay any taxes.
- [Loddy] Who to pay 'em to? Myself?
My nigga, my pimp, what?
(interviewer laughs)
- [Interviewer] What was
the best time of your life?
- The best time of my life, really?
That's embarrassing (laughing).
The best time of my life?
I was at the beach and...
I was in Talexico across the border,
this guy named Alex Martinez,
he sent for me in an Uber.
I was at my friend Alicia house
and I was gettin' into it with everybody.
I was having a bad week
and he sent for me,
said, go to Western Union,
give them these numbers,
make sure you have your ID
and once you get that call me.
I go to Western Union and get my ID
and they gave me back $3,000.
I called him, I'm like,
"What's this money for?"
He like, "Um, your Lyft will be outside
in front of Alicia
house like in 30 minutes
so just be ready."
He say, "Just come like that with you
and what I sent you with."
I'm like, "Okay."
So, I'm sitting there,
waiting, waiting, waiting.
Lyft come and I was in there like,
"Where am I going to?"
They was like, "Oh, you going to, um,
a three to four hour drive.
I'm about to take you all the way across
the border to Talexico."
I'm like, "What the fuck, like."
And remind you, I'm
already on the freeway,
like, like, "Where am I going?"
Like you know, I was
noticing I was on the freeway
for a long time.
I done seen the graveyard, I seen cows
and all type of shit.
I'm like, "Where the
fuck am I going, like,
where is he sending me to?"
And I go out there
and he bought me my own car.
I had a Mitsubishi.
Um...
He took me on the beach.
He took me on a boat ride, like...
See, then when I, when I went out there,
I picked up on another drug.
I stopped doin' coke.
I started doing meth.
I was on the beach.
I was smokin'.
I was just, like, living like,
living like a queen, like,
you know, like, I don't know.
I went out there and I didn't come back
for almost maybe, from that one time
he sent for me, I never
came back to California
for maybe like six, seven, eight months.
My mama and then thought somebody
had kidnapped me or something,
I got, like, 'cause I didn't call nobody.
I didn't say nothing.
I was really just too wrapped up in it,
I was out there for just a good, like,
just started from nothing
and lived my life like from there.
Like literally didn't call anyone.
Um, how I got in contact with my family
was that, um, me and
him was taking pictures
and somebody commented on a picture
and was like, "Tell
Loddy to contact her mom.
It's an emergency."
Like, 911, when they said
that and I realized it,
remind you I was already out there
for maybe about a good three months.
I'm like, "Fuck, let me
call home," like, I'm just,
just, just, just ran on
and just forgot about my whole career,
my life I had behind
me, like, and I'm like,
"I'm in Mexico, I'm like,
I'm here with my friend."
And they was like, "Come home,"
and I'm like, like, come home?
What, like...
And then by then now, I was already 18,
I was grown, so I'm like, "Come home?
Like, I like it out here,
what you mean come home."
I'm gonna stay here.
- [Interviewer] You were
having the time of your life.
- I stayed out there.
I started gettin' into shit.
I got a job and oh, Lord, from there
I got a house and I started selling drugs
and then we got held for ransom.
All type of shit happened, like,
I was fuckin' around with the cartels.
That shit was just, I don't know,
it got ugly, then I came back
and then I was going back and forth
and now I'm here.
Like, I didn't, for me, eventually,
just that little bit
expanded, like, a lot.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Have I been in love?
I was in love two times in my life.
No.
I was in love two times in my whole life
with a guy named Daniel Kyle
and a boy name Demonte Morgan.
That's it.
I loves no one.
I love myself.
- [Interviewer] Does
doing this for a living
get in the way of your
romantic relationships?
Make them more difficult?
- No, 'cause if I had a nigga,
well, if I had a boyfriend right now,
well, for guys that really know me
and we been in certain relationships
or we been in a little whatever,
I don't know, we've been on dates
or been knowing each other, like,
niggas, know how I like myself,
niggas know how I like to be treated,
niggas know how my attitude is,
niggas know how my mood swings are.
They know how to deal
with me, approach me,
have me around certain people.
You know, they just know how
to do me, like, you know,
so it's really not too many, you know,
like guys out there that,
like, I let even look
at me like that or look at me.
They look at me more as like a homegirl
or a sister type wise, 'cause like
I'm a girly at the end of the day,
but a majority of the
time, I'm like, you know,
I'm like the gutter gutter girl,
you know, you know, I got
like a lot of personalities,
you know, so it's like,
you can rub me this way,
I'll be this way one day,
you can rub me that way
and I'll be that way.
- [Interviewer] You think
living this lifestyle
has changed you?
- Maybe. It could be. Yeah.
Yeah, 'cause it turns,
it turns me all the ways
that I know I shouldn't be turnin'
and it's, at the end of the day
when I look back it's
nothin' for me to be ashamed,
wait, yeah, no, 'cause
I'm grown, so it's like
who gives a fuck?
Like, you know, I love
my mom, I love my dad.
It's no disrespect, like,
you know they raised me
to be a young lady, you know,
and be the woman I am.
But I just choose to go my routes
and go my ways, you know.
I mean, on my freeway there's no traffic
if you don't get in the wrong lane.
- [Interviewer] You think you're addicted
to the lifestyle?
The fast money and the...
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] Lack of responsibility?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And the danger?
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] It'd be
very hard to quit, right?
- I'll don't, I don't never quit.
I don't never give up.
Mama told me whatever I do, be best at it.
Be the, be the better,
be the better out of it.
Make sure I do it, whatever it is.
She didn't raise no quitter.
Now that's what she didn't do.
- [Interviewer] Are you able to stand
outside of yourself and
look at what you're doing
and see how-
- Yep, all the time.
When I wanna be just,
when I wanna be (speaking
foreign language),
I'll get me a room, be with myself,
get me what I want, get
me my, whatever, whatever,
and I'll go in there and just chill
and I'll just look at
myself, like, you know?
I can be this person one day,
I could be that person the next day.
I choose to be the way I am because,
maybe 'cause I don't have a baby.
- [Interviewer] You have a child?
- I have no kids.
I'm a woman of my own,
I'm a baby of both sides,
of Mom and Dad, and they have,
I'm the baby, both sides,
so it's, you know.
It's left up to me sometime
at the end of the day,
but, no, it's not, 'cause my sisters
and brothers, they having
a lot of little, you know,
they got a lot of 'em, so they
don't need nothing outta me.
Real shit.
- [Interviewer] Would you
describe yourself as happy?
- No.
I'm humble.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think drove you down
this path in life?
It's unusual, especially
coming from a good childhood.
It's an unusual choice, right?
- Being outside.
Being outside seeing things that I wanted,
that I knew Mom and Dad wouldn't get.
- [Interviewer] So you grew
up close to the streets
and you saw girls doing this
and it just kind of became tempting?
- I mean, not really, because that means
I was a follower.
I just seen certain stuff that I wanted
and I was always that type
of girl when I want it,
I for sure got that shit,
believe that, like, I mean
what my mind always, I seen
or if I lay my eye on it
or whatever, whatever, trust me.
Nines out of 10, I promised
you I touched it and got it.
It mighta haven't been all the way mine's,
but I got it and put it in
my possession to, you know,
to whatever, whatever it is.
I don't think my mind seen or thought
or had any actions on anything
that I have not touched yet.
Thousands of dollars, almost,
probably a few meal tickets, shit.
I done run through money,
cars, house, everything.
I done had it all and lost it.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your
years of doing this?
- You can't take nothin' back.
Once, I mean once it's gone, it's gone.
You start something, you
better be bound to finish it.
If you're on a good path,
stay on a good path.
You on a fucked up path,
me personally, I think if
you on a fucked up path,
stay on a fucked up path.
Don't, don't try to go straight
and then fuck up and then go straight.
It don't go.
If you gonna fuck up, fuck up all the way.
If you gonna go straight, straight,
go straight all the way.
You know, 'cause when you do good
and then you fuck up and then
you try to do good,
it makes you have problems in life
and then when you be bad, then be good,
then be bad, you have problems in life.
It follows you a thousand miles
and it makes it hard for you to try
to even become yourself or try to be
that person that you know you need to be
or you want somebody to
know or respect you as.
You know what I'm sayin', like,
you can't grow up bein' a thief
and when you get older
and not expect no one
to be like, oh, yeah, I know her,
like she was perfect person.
Motherfuckers see you and
like, oh, yeah, I know her,
she was a thief back then,
you know, shit like that.
Or yeah, I knew her, she was
smart all her fuckin' life,
like she, you know, she won't,
you can't put nothin' past her,
like she's A1.
Somewhere down that line,
that bitch foul as a motherfucker.
You know what I'm sayin', so it's like,
you gonna be good, be good.
You gonna be bad, do your shit.
Just know, every action has a reaction.
It's just karma like a motherfucker.
I believe in it, 'cause I'll
be out there certain days
and it'd be, you know, dog, it's,
like every dog got its day,
like, you know, it's been some days
I just be wantin' to give up
and it don't even be no reason about it,
like, but it's 'cause I put up the fight
for just everything.
I got, I have to make sure
everything, everything.
I can't be out there without no money
because how I was raised,
I never went without.
You know, I never was the kid that,
that needed something.
I always had everything
I wanted right there.
Now, it's like I'm, I'm, I don't even have
to be out there on my own,
but now that I'm out there on my own
and I wanna live the life and all this,
I have to make sure I have
this, this, that, everything costs.
Every time you step
out the door, it costs.
You can't go outside with just a dollar.
Oh, no, I don't think you'll survive.
That's out.
Every time you go out the
house, you gotta have money.
- [Interviewer] All right, Loddy.
Thank you so much for
the interesting talk.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] You're fascinating.
Thank you very much.